اذا مشاهدينا بعد ما يقارب اربعه اشهر على
او اربع اربعه اشهر على بدا الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه نسج الاطباء شبكه مخيفه لمساعده
جرح الاحتجاجات الذين يتم تعاقبهم في
المستشفيات العامه صحيفه لوفيغاغور
الفرنسيه نقلت عن طبيب ايراني قوله ان
المستشفيات الايرانيه كانت تحت رقابه
مشدده منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات لذلك كان من
المستحيل ان يتوجه المتظاهرون المصابون
الى هناك تجنبا لاعتقالهم من قبل النظام
ويقول الطبيب الذي حول غرفه معيشته الى
غرفه عمليات ان المصابين اغلبهم من الشباب
والنساء وقال طبيب اخر للصحيفه ان القوات
الامن فتحت النار على مئات الاطباء اثناء
التجمع احتجاجه وايضا اثناء التجمعهم امام
مجلس النظام الايراني في اكتوبر الماضي
ويصف الطبيب حاله احد المتظاهرات التي تم
احضارها الى منزله حيث احصى ما لا يقل عن
و80 شظيه من ال- اا في جميع انحاء جسد
الفتاه ووفقا ايضا لشهادات جمعتها الصحيفه
من جميع انحاء البلاد فان عناصر النظام
يستهدفون عمدا اجزاء حساسه من الجسم وعلى
وجه الخصوص الوجه واسفل البطن والساقين
هذا وتمكنت قوات الامن من اعتقال العديد
من الاطباء بينهم ايمان نافابي وهو جراح
من بلده سندس التركي الكرديه عفوا كان
يساعد الجرح سرا بعدما نشر هذا الفيديو
الذي يظهره بجوار سرير احد المتظاهرين وهو
يكلمه بعد مقام بمداواته كما نشاهده هنا
[موسيقى]
جديده